tristan mckenzie fastball curveball
slider change jp crawford leads it off
batting left-handed the shortstop
four straight
and the leadoff man is aboard
now renee rivera is going to the
mountain and again
if you're an indians fan this sounds
really redundant and here comes
the indians
pitching coach carl willis and trainer
james quinlan oh boy i mean james
quinlan is not coming out there unless
they feel like something is wrong with
mackenzie now the set by mackenzie the
high hold and the 3-1 pitch
way inside and high and it's ball four
and back-to-back walks
phil maton has grabbed a baseball and
he's getting loose again start here
where you you could be into that first
inning he backed up mejia in st louis
when he couldn't get out of the first
inning sometimes as we know the harder
you try the worse it gets yeah exactly
there you go there we go four pitch walk
and that's it he's seen enough he gave
him that last hitter he's giving him
every opportunity he could possibly have
at another time an indian starter cannot
get out of the first
one pitch away
from getting the indians out of this
mess
and a swing and a mess elevated the
fastball got him
say kakuchi
he has 12 start on the earth three and
three record era just over four
and 66 and two thirds 69 strikeouts for
you say now the 2-1
swung on bang to third backhanded by
seeger he'll go to second one moore's
relay in the dirt what a great pick by
jake bowers an ending ending double play
live drive left center field that's a
gaffer
[Applause]
short hops the wall and harold ramirez
was fired in but not before tom murphy
has himself a double his sixth of the
year and he is one mariner that has been
swinging the bat pretty well batting 281
in his last 11 games coming in yeah
first hit of the ball again it's a
breaking ball but it's down and in
murphy goes down hits it into the left
center field gap
to third fair ball
it's gonna be safe and big harold's
going to second why not
close play
safe
it's one and two here to owen miller
adding in the eight hole
gotti walks off defiantly i like that
a couple of runners stranded one-nothing
you say kikuchi in the mariners
crawly walt uh walked his first time up
at a long at bat 10 pitch at that
jake leans into this one and it's way
gone jake bradley
third home run of the season a two-run
shot the mariners have a three-nothing
lead
well he got a pitch in the zone he
wanted and
man did he get all of them they sit here
would go a long way
but ramirez on deck
good pitch oh oh come on now that was a
late call wasn't it not only was it late
it wasn't a strike
in the whole long throw
jose beats it out and i'll tell you a
good hustle by jose down the line
and that's going to be their second hit
but both hits are infield singles for
the indians
and you know what that's the thing about
ramirez you know you're going to get
your all every time he goes down the
line
900th career hit congratulations
there's demo that'll be extra basis he
can run
he's always out of the box hard he's
thinking
two of the slide he's in there safely
here's the pitch
and on the move with the pitch toward
third is more the throw not in time he's
safe at third base
not going was bowers
but it's a stolen base of third for
dylan moore here's the pitch on the way
swing and a miss and a fastball up and
in for strike three stefan here's the
next pitch on the way fastball swing and
a miss for strike three and stefan gets
out of a jam
a couple of high fastballs and a
curveball
oh that balance
he's sitting there minding his own
business and all comes right to him
oh he got into that one
high and deep and there it goes home run
dylan moore
demo welcome back looking like having an
impact on your first day
in the air left field back goes eddie
still going back
and leaps up
and made the catch holy smokes want to
play
wow
dynamite
piece of larceny
by eddie rosario
[Applause]
there's a ball hit well deep right
center field back it goes goodbye
10th home run of the year for cesar
hernandez
tying run at the plate bottom of the
ninth
2-1 pitch
broken back that's going to get down
coming around third bradley zimmer will
score naylors into third
bobby bradley off the bench with a pinch
hit two out rbi single
302
in the air deep left are you kidding me
all the way to the wall of defense
naylor scores
bradley is home with the tying run
an 02 slider
and it just stayed right there down and
in he hits it off the wall thought it
might have a chance to go out
but everybody up and running with two
outs it's gonna tie the ball game
the indians have a chance to walk it off
now look at that are you kidding me
how about this for respect even without
first base being open the mariners are
going to walk jose ramirez to load the
bases with nobody out here we go infield
in
right back to him oh he threw it away
bogan's over the indians win it
absolutely unbelievable
a double play ball hit back to the
pitcher
he almost airmailed the throw and murphy
with a leaping catch
had no chance to get the sliding cesar
hernandez
an unfastable finish to this ball game